British actor Dan Stevens dives
headfirst into the role of the Marvel
Comics character David Haller whose
diagnosis of schizophrenia may actually
be masking his mutant abilities in the
TV show legion yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers it's Jan here and in this video
I'm going to be revealing some
fascinating facts you might not know
about the making of the mind-bending new
series from Fargo showrunner Noah Hawley
leach in the TV series didn't start out
as we know it today back in 2014
following the success of the first
season of Fargo the producers behind the
x-men film franchise approached Fargo
showrunner Noah Hawley about making an
x-men TV series first at that stage the
story of David Haller aka Legion was not
the one on the table
the original idea put forward to Hawley
with a show about the Hellfire Club
which previously appeared on the big
screen in x-men first class however
Hawley who grew up reading x-men comics
wasn't keen on bringing that world to
the small screen or in making a
straightforward comic book adaptation
instead he wanted to add something fresh
playful and unexpected to the genre so
he chose the character of David Haller
which allowed him to explore identity
question reality and make a show where
the audience would do the same in
Marvel's comics David Haller has
multiple personalities and is a super
powerful mutant son of Professor X the
character was created in the mid-1980s
by Chris Claremont and Bill Sync evich
by the way Fox did start developing
another TV show but the Hellfire Club
with different show runners but that
particular idea was shut down when Fox
decided the Drac Hellfire script didn't
work as a TV series and the showrunners
began work on the new series 24 legacy
instead when it came to developing
Legion Noah Hawley was inspired by a
variety of British films from the 60s
and 70s including Quadrophenia and
Stanley Kubrick's A Clockwork Orange in
fact he wanted the series to have a
similar vibe to the kind of movies
British actor Terrence stamps made in
the 1960s however because Hawley views
this new show is a kind of fable and
because it focuses on protagonist david
hauless very subjective and fractured
experience of the world
negan isn't set in one particular time
period or location so it's the real look
ranges from the past to present-day
right into the future another major
influence on the series with British
rock band Pink Floyd and their classic
1973 Al's on the Dark Side of the Moon
which Hawley described as a soundscape
of mental illness in fact the character
that actress Rachel Heller plays is
named after one of Pink Floyd's founding
members Syd Barrett who like David
Holland may have been schizophrenic the
band also inspired the show's music
which is a mix of electronic orchestral
and atonal sounds tape effects and music
playing backwards
indeed composer Jeff Rousseau told the
Marvel reporter nur defiles blog that he
bought the kind of synthesizer used on
Dark Side of the Moon in order to
channel the right sound Russo who's a
fan of Pink Floyd and 82 x-men comics
knew his music needed to capture david
hauless sense of uncertainty about
what's real and what isn't while moving
perfectly between those two worlds and
he found that reading neurologist Oliver
Sacks his book hallucinations helped him
understand how people like David Haller
you hear voices perceive reality during
auditory hallucinations speaking of
music to help Stan Stephens get into the
right head space to play Haller
showrunner Noah Hawley put together a
special playlist for him the 160 tracks
that Hawley chose were an extremely
eclectic mix ranging from music such as
Pink Floyd to the mutton people
screaming into bins and experimental
French sound off Nietzsche may be its
own standalone show at the moment but
you should still look out for x-men
nodes in the series in fact a bunch of
props that featured in the x-men movies
and which are normally kept in storage
was shipped to the soundstage in
Vancouver where Lisa was filming
showrunner Noah Hawley has pretty much
had a carte blanche and bringing the
character of Li Jin to the small screen
so keep your eyes peeled throughout
season ones eight episodes to see which
x-men movie props he snuck into the show
so guys what did you think of Legion and
what other x-men characters would you
like to see get their own show if you
enjoyed this video do comment like and
hit that subscribe button plus don't
forget to turn on your notifications so
you don't miss out on my latest videos
and while you're here why not click or
tap the screen to check out my other
comic book movie and TV videos thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers